il cherche terre d'accueil pour ces
habitants menacés par la montée des eaux
1192 îles qui menacent de disparaître
sous les eaux de l'océan indien décrire
jour les mâles disparaissait sous les
eaux retour à la fin des années 80 l'onu
s'inquiète du sort des petits états
insulaires en développement
ils ont en commun une taille réduite une
dispersion géographique un isolement de
leur marché et une limitation de leurs
ressources
mais surtout une menace nous vivons sur
des îles qui se trouve quasiment au
niveau de la mer où quelques mètres au
dessus et le résultat c'est que nous
serons inondé la mer recouvrira la terre
et nous aurons plus d'endroit où vivre
pitau non bon pêche télé vous face à
cette menace les ils se mobilisent dès
1990 en une organisation
intergouvernementale avec un but se
faire entendre lors des négociations
internationales
cette conférence sera face à face d'un
côté les pays d'asie et du pacifique
menacées de voir leur pays inondé ou
submergés si le réchauffement de la
terre continue au rythme actuel
de l'autre les pays industrialisés
pollueurs numéro 1 de l'atmosphère
l'organisation des petits états
insulaires multiplié les actions
médiatiques comme en 2009 par exemple
mais mal d'organiser un conseil des
ministres sous l'eau pour sensibiliser
la communauté internationale cette
situation est un défi et nous voulons
nous assurer que le monde est aussi
préoccupé que nous le sommes et nous
voulons que les gens fassent quelque
chose
malgré ces actions la communauté
internationale restent sourdes et le
débat sur le droit d'asile
environnementale est toujours en
pourparlers en revanche désaccords entre
pays voisins se prépare où ont déjà eu
lieu exemple aux îles marshall
en 2015 la population anticipe ce
phénomène et commencent déjà à quitter
le pays sur près de soixante dix mille
habitants
dix mille se sont exilés aux etats unis
et plus particulièrement dans cette
petite ville de l'arkansas un accord
entre le deux pays facilite leur
installation
des accords qui ne font pas l'unanimité
car certains habitants de ces îles
préfèrent rester chez eux tout en
s'adaptant à cette montée des eaux
inéluctable
[Musique]